Speaker 1: In fact, why don't we go to
Nico from Illinois? Nico from Illinois.
Welcome to the program. What is
on your mind today? Hello. Nico.
Nico, we heard you. I don't
know why you muted yourself.
Speaker 3: Ah, there we go. Hey,
David was the first time calling in,
and I kind of just had a question about social
media and influencers and how they subliminally
push kind of right wing ideas. Mm hmm. And how
they kind of get these kids that follow them to
believe in to these right wing ideas.
Speaker 1: And what's an example.
Speaker 3: Kind of educate them.
Speaker 1: What's an example?
Speaker 3: I just would like Andrew Tate and all
that stuff that's going on with him. I feel like
there's a lot of. Influencers out there
that kind of like support him and try to
make him seem like he's this really cool guy.
Speaker 1: See, here's the thing about that.
Here's my thought, Nico. And this is an ongoing
conversation that that we can have. And I just
I'm not sure. It seems that these types of people
appeal to exactly the same folks. And what I mean
by that is, you know, I did this segment a few
weeks ago about Liver King and Andrew Tate and
Jordan Peterson. And I didn't mean to say that
they are the same in their ideologies. In fact,
they are quite different. But the point was
they end up pulling in basically young men,
often with less going on socially than they
would like, often less relational, you know,
less involved in relationships than they would
like often without a defined or successful career
path yet. And so they end up being different
flavors of characters that pull in the same types
of people. And I'll give you an example. I don't
know anybody, and I'm sure they exist anecdotally,
but I don't know anyone who works in, you know,
has a good job as a lawyer or as an accountant or,
you know, even a success, whatever, and is sitting
there watching Andrew Tate videos, you know what
I mean? It just it seems like it's mostly young
men that get sucked in. So while I agree with you
that it's a bad thing that these figures pull
people into this sort of like pseudo right wing,
pull yourself up by your bootstraps type
ideology, it's really only afflicting a
particular demographic group overwhelmingly.
Speaker 3: Right. And I was just just I was
just wondering this because I had seen
a report that supposedly in the U.K.,
they're kind of like reteaching these young kids
the try to get them away from these like Andrew
Tate effect and all that stuff. So, yeah, I just
didn't know if that was like a good way to go at
it or is just kind of like a waste of time because
at the end of the day, these kids are going to go
home and just watch what they want to watch.
Speaker 1: That's true. And you know, I know
a high school principal I was recently, it's
actually a middle and high school principal. And
she was telling me that she's aware of seventh and
eighth graders who watch Andrew Tate. And that's
really the risk because these these kids haven't
even really defined anything about themselves
yet. And that's where it's like now that's
that seems like a particularly pernicious age
at which to be consuming that type of nonsense.
Speaker 3: Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Yeah. And like,
it's not like they kind of let you form your
own opinion, you know, they kind of just force
this stuff on you and. Yeah, and without a
doubt, it's just not something that I would
want my kid to be exposed to, you know?
Speaker 1: I agree. I agree. Well,
I appreciate the call.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Thank you
for taking my call, sir.
Speaker 1: All right,
Take care. There is Nico from Illinois.
Very important declarations, I think.